okay now now down to cognitive ability
well how can you conceptualize
intelligence well this is a major
problem because your initial
conceptualization determines in part the
strategies that you're going to use to
investigate intelligence and when you
say when you when you pair a sentence
down to what is intelligence the
sentence is problematic because part of
it is a question about if and how such a
thing might manifest itself in the world
so there's a fact out there or set of
facts that corresponds to intelligence
but the other problem is well what do
you mean when you say intelligence and
you kind of have to nail that down if
you're going to have a conversation
about intelligence that doesn't go
entirely astray and so you've got it
you've got a definitional problem as
well as an empirical problem and so
there have been and this was especially
true in the 1990s people have been
studying intelligence IQ intelligence
since the 1920s and it is a very
well-established branch of psychology
one of the things I have to tell you
about it IQ Research is that if you
don't buy IQ research you might as well
throw away all the rest of psychology
and the reason for that is that the
psychologists first of all who developed
intelligence testing were among the
early psychologists who instantiated the
statistical techniques that all
psychologists use to verify and test all
of their hypotheses so you end up
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
and the IQ people have defined
intelligence in a more stringent
stringent and accurate way than we've
been able to define almost any other
psychological construct and so if you
toss out the one that's most well
defined then you're kind of stuck with
the problem of what are you going to do
with all the ones that you have left
over that are nowhere near as well
defined
or as well measured or as or as or or
whose predictive validity is much less
and has been demonstrated with much less
vigor and clarity
anyways despite all that
people have posited a number of
different intelligences and reasonably
so because there's a if you think of
intelligence as that which might move
you forward successfully in the world
obviously there's a fair number of
phenomena that are associated with
individuals that might fit into that
category so we have people have made
these distinctions Bob Sternberg for
example is distinguished between
practical versus analytical intelligence
and he kind of thinks of practical as
like street smarts and has attempted to
dissociate that from the kind of
analytical intelligence that that
characterizes more straight IQ research
I don't think he's done it successfully
as well at all and since the 1990s
interest in his practical intelligence
has declined precipitously because when
it is matched head-to-head with standard
IQ intelligence the IQ intelligence eats
up all the variability what's really
happened as far as I can tell so far is
that when we're trying to predict
people's course through life IQ does a
very good job and then one of the traits
does a very good job as well which is
conscientiousness but it doesn't do as
good a job as IQ now that partly might
be because we can't measure
conscientiousness very well we're stuck
with self reports or maybe I could
gather peer reports about you or I could
gather your parents reports about your
teachers reports and each of those seems
to pick up a little bit more of the
pattern because you know yourself but
other people know you differently than
you know yourself and there's still some
accuracy in that you can get multiple
rater reports of something like
conscientiousness and that'll up it's
predictive validity but in the final
analysis the best you seem to be able to
deal with conscientiousness is about a
point for correlation with long term
performance whereas with IQ in complex
jobs you can probably get 0.5 and maybe
point six and so 0.5 is 25% of the
variance you got to square it point six
is thirty percent 36 percent of the
variance and point four is sixteen
percent of the variance so even at the
low end let's say high end for
conscientiousness is 0.4 or 16 percent
low-end for IQ is 0.5 or 25% low-end
estimates of IQ make it one and a half
times more powerful than the high-end
estimates of conscientiousness and I
think that's about right you'd think why
do we even have to debate this and
because it's so bloody obvious to me
that intelligence is a major predictor
of life success I mean you people I've
measured the IQ of University of Toronto
people you know people in this room who
have an IQ of less than 120 are rare
well why well smart people go to
university now is that actually a
contentious statement what shouldn't be
a contentious statement it's
self-evident universities were actually
set up so that smart people could expand
their abilities that's why they were
there and you're selected on the basis
of assessments that are essentially
there to assess something like
intelligence yes but that will that's a
12 count Reversi is it reasonable and
this is a measurement issue and that's
why we're that's why I've been
instructing you to some degree in
psychometrics because we actually know
how to do this we know how to answer
that question so let's take a look at
how at how intelligence has been
assessed and why and then you can make
up your own mind anyways here's some of
the examples of other forms of
intelligence and so then the question is
well what does it mean to have a
different form of intelligence would
would form a inform B be completely
uncorrelated like extraversion say in
neuroticism or would they be slightly
correlated or would they be highly
correlated and then you might ask well
how highly correlated did they have to
be before they're the same thing
or how uncorrelated do they have to be
before they're different things and
actually the answer to that comes down
to something like practical utility it's
like imagine I'm trying to figure out
how well you'll do in University and I
measure one thing and it's correlated at
0.7 with another thing I measure about
you then I might say well are those two
things the same or different they're
pretty highly correlated you're high in
one it means you're going to be high in
the other well so what is there any
utility in measuring both things and the
way you figure that out actually is you
do it statistically so we take the
target which might be
your performance across university and
then we say well can we predict your
performance across university better by
using one variable or two variables so
we would enter them both into a
regression equation all a regression
equation does it's quite simple so
you're trying to predict the target and
the regression age the regression
equation tells you how well you can
predict that target if you know another
fact now then it gets a little
complicated because that's a correlation
how well you can predict B with a well a
regression will say how much you can
predict C if you know a and B or a and B
and C and D and E because you can use
multiple predictors and you can weight
them so it might be 2 times a plus 1
times B equals C and that's all a
regression equation does it's just
multiplication and addition very very
straightforward and so two variables are
sufficiently different functionally if
you can use both of them simultaneously
to predict something of interest so
again it's a tool like approach this is
how the cycle nutritions do it is
something real well it's real if you can
measure measure it it helps you predict
that's that's how its defined so then
you might say well are are there these
multiple intelligences well the first
question would be well what do you mean
by are there and the answer to that
would be well let's specify the question
since we're going to be scientific about
it let's predict how well people do in
university we'll start with the
assumption that intelligence if
intelligence isn't associated with
university success then you're probably
not talking about intelligence now you
could argue that right because you could
say well intelligence has nothing to do
with university success but that's a
definitional matter we'd have to agree
to begin with is it reasonable to start
with the presupposition that
intelligence and university success
share something in common well I think
you have to be daft to to deny that
initial proposition although you could
because you could say it was privileged
or socioeconomic status or or or or at
any number of sociological phenomena and
some of those are obviously relevant
social class for example because you
know
if you're in a higher social class and
all things being equal intelligence
included if you're in a higher social
class you're more likely to go to
university than you are if you're in a
lower social class so there's other
there's other factors that are going to
influence whether or not you do well in
university but we're going to assume
that one of them might be intelligence
well then you would ask well if you
measured social intelligence so that's
what do they call that social
intelligence know emotional intelligence
which does not exist by the way
emotional intelligence moral
intelligence linguistic musical logical
mathematical spatial body kinesthetic
interpersonal and interpersonal all
different forms of intelligence ok so to
answer the question of whether they
exist what you do first is pick a target
prediction of university performance
then you make a measure for each of them
then you test to see if the measure
measured the same thing across multiple
instances within the same person that's
a reliability test because what the hell
good is your ruler if it stretches when
you use it has to measure the same thing
multiple times and then you would say ok
we'll take all these different
intelligences measured the way we've
decided to measure them the first thing
we'll do is see how highly correlated
they are because if they're complete two
of them are completely correlated then
you have one you don't have to because
that's the virtually the definition of
one instead of two you can factor
analyze them and see if you can pull out
what's common across all of them that's
another thing because then you might say
well intelligence is what's common
across all the measures of these
intelligences it's it's a proposition
it's not a fact you have to decide if
you're going to agree with it but that
if you were going to do that you'd use a
factor analysis and you'd say well if
someone was more likely to be musical if
they were also high in linguistic
ability and more likely to be logical
and mathematically inclined if they had
a high spatial ability etc then you'd be
hypothesizing that there was one factor
behind all of those manifestations that
somehow similar and maybe there wouldn't
be and then you take all your measures
and you put them in something like a
multiple regression analysis and you'd
predict your target University
performance and then maybe you'd say
well wait a minute let's not just use
university performance let's use junior
high performance
high school performance university
performance and job success and then
let's say that the only things that
predict success across all of those
categories and that are the same we're
going to define as intelligence well
that's basically how you end up with IQ
you could say that IQ is what's common
across all possible sets of intelligence
tests now people are going to debate
that because you still have to define
what constitutes a test but the way the
psychometricians have managed it and
have taken care of this at least to some
degree is to say well we're going to
we're not going to define everything
that we measure as intelligence so
extroverted people are more socially
fluent are we gonna call that
intelligence no we're gonna call that
personality we're going to call that
extraversion and we're gonna call stress
tolerance you could say well if you can
tolerate more stress you're more
intelligent it's like well no that isn't
how we've defined it we're gonna define
that as being lower in neuroticism if
your cooperative you're more intelligent
that's emotional intelligence well what
you're less intelligent if you're
competitive well no so we've parsed that
off to agreeableness so then the
question might be is there anything left
of these so-called intelligences once
you control for personality and IQ and
the answer is no nothing nothing left of
them and the people who keep pushing
these ideas keep trying to push them
because they don't like the idea of real
individual differences and to me that's
just a matter of sticking your damn head
in the sand because it's obvious here
you're gonna have a child you want the
child to have an IQ of 65 or 145 decide
okay so you're all gonna vote okay you
think any one of you is gonna vote to
have a child with an IQ of 65 that
child's gonna have a hard time
developing even linguistic ability
they're never going to learn to read
right they're never gonna leave home in
all likelihood
so which child are you going to pick
well so do you believe in intelligence
or not well obviously if you have any
sense